hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions for
this week's flash arrow community
because of all the Batman V Superman
stuff you know Aquaman Jason Momoa this
is going to be all things DC and giant
high-fives to everyone that got badges
for San Diego comic-con don't worry if
you didn't there's still all kinds of
off-site stuff that you can do without
an official San Diego comic-con badge
99% of the stuff there that everyone
wants to see you'll be able to see
online so even if you don't go you'll
still be able to see all the trailers
the teasers all that stuff eventually
and just like the last couple of years
i'll be posting as many panels as
possible and i'll be i'll be doing a
bunch of giveaway so don't worry
there'll be a lot of fun stuff happening
it's not going to be to the beginning of
july so i'm gonna announce my comic con
plants whenever we get closer to that
now let's just start the Q&A with Batman
vs Superman stuff under that's what most
everyone's talking about right now there
are a few general questions that a lot
of you guys had that I can answer just
right away so first off the justice
league itself isn't going to be a thing
till the Justice League movie we're just
gonna see the beginnings of that at the
end of Batman vs Superman add to that
Aquaman even though he's like the first
teaser image here he's going to be a
small presence in the film too I think I
mentioned it in my breakdown yesterday
but most of the movies going to focus on
Batman and Superman technically it's not
a man of steel sequel it's more of a
Justice League prequel really I think
the intention of the film is just to see
how people react to having a lot of DC
characters in a movie together before
they do a real justice league film think
of it as a dry run for justice league
and I know everyone wants to know when
that first trailer is going to come if
they don't attach it to one of their big
movies in the next couple of months
which i'm not expecting i think that
they'll just hold it for comic-con that
they just seems like the likely
candidate it falls within about a
10-month period of the movie and they
usually don't release the first trailer
till they get within the one year window
so just in general was probably gonna
happen is Warner Brothers will do like a
big hall h panel will the role the cast
out do something really special then
they'll air the official trailer and
then eventually posted online moving
into the TV universe now though arrow
and flash stuff here we go first
question Jeffrey S who was the other
prisoner on the island that was probably
Captain Boomerang they didn't say his
name out loud but you know is probably
them we can get the fans he's a member
of the Suicide Squad he knew Slade
Wilson Oliver put him on the island when
I said I mean at the end of the brave in
the bold episode episode 8 he said he
put him somewhere where
no one would find him the teaser and
that being that he was going to put him
in the island I can't remember who it
was someone from the show it might have
been Marc Guggenheim said that the
reason that they didn't have him in the
episode that Slade didn't let him out
whenever slave was escaping is because
he didn't want to share resources but
logically the actor wasn't available and
they did they didn't want to crowd the
episode with too much logic yes Thea and
Oliver could defeat Addie powered Slade
but there's no way they would have been
able to defeat Addie powered Slade and
Captain Boomerang at the same time and
the whole arc of that island storyline
was defeating Slade without having to
kill him next question red arrow ass do
you think that Felicity will wind up
leaving team arrow to join Ray Palmer
now that he has the atom suit no I mean
she's not gonna quit team arrow she
might be on the outs with Oliver she
might not be super happy with him right
now but that doesn't mean that she's
gonna quit the team a lot of people have
also asked if Felicity would leave the
show if they end up doing an atom TV
show in Marc Guggenheim has already
confirmed that Felicity isn't going
anywhere she's always going to be on
arrow if she does go on any other shows
or any other new spin-offs that they do
it'll just be as a guest star it'll be
like when she went on the flash next
question pixel pillager asks if Thea
becomes part of team arrow will she find
out about Barry's powers if they do
another crossover yeah I think that's a
pretty safe assumption the funny thing
is is when they did the flare o
crossover what are we going to call it
the brave and the bold Barry just kind
of zoomed right in he had the best
reaction to that too he's like up sorry
my bad I think he had run out to get
Chinese food he was just like super
hungry we can do a tally at the end of
both the seasons to see how many new
people learned the identity of the flash
in the arrow but every new season
they'll always be new people that will
find out next question tolland ass
Stephen Amell has been stirring up
trouble on facebook again there was a
picture with the arrow Arsenal and black
Canary with the tag capturing some
things for the very last time so what
you're asking is you know does that
imply one of those characters leaving
the show like Roy perhaps no I don't
think that's the case yes Colton Haynes
has been doing some weird stuff on
social media right now in terms of
production they haven't shot the finale
yet so there's still episodes left to
film I think this picture is from
episode 18 or 19 maybe episode 19 the
title of episode 19 is broken arrow in
addition to like the list of possible
meanings that that could have one
them is that it was a control word used
by sports master to control a clone of
Roy Harper so something could be
happening to Roy after this episode that
would mean that he would not be running
around in his red suit with team arrow
for the rest of the season and when I
say the rest of the season I mean like
the last three episodes what I'd like to
see happen is team arrow try to
infiltrate the League of Assassins and
do so by sending Roy into the belly of
the beast finding some reason for him to
join the League of Assassins so that
would mean he'd be able to leave team
arrow without completely leaving the
show I have no idea where season four is
headed what their intentions are they're
obviously not going to kill off racial
cool because he's way too big of a
character but I think it'd be really bad
asked if they had one of their
characters go inside the league for a
little while next question fatal fist
desks so you're asking ken well split
himself into two people and did he make
a copy of himself in episode 9 whenever
he was fighting himself technically no I
think what we're seeing right here is
him just moving so fast backwards and
forwards between two points that it
looks like there's two of them if you
look at the promo for episode 15 what it
looks like is happening is cisco is
analyzing camera footage and he's just
going frame by frame so he sees really
blurry image of Harrison wells split
into two because he's moving so fast so
technically it's not two distinct people
it's just Harrison wells jumping back
and forth between two points really fast
he would have had to put on and take off
his reverse flash costume and switch
positions think about how fast he'd have
to be moving to do that next question
Eternal Darkness ass I wonder if they're
going to do a flashpoint paradox story
for their next crossover between air on
the flash and shows some future heroes
but but not say who they are I'm not
sure if you're talking about heroes from
the future in terms of time or heroes
that they're going to bring on in the
future season I think what they would do
if they did time travel in an episode
they would just keep it really
self-contained just going based on the
the arrow flash crossover from last year
generally if there's going to be any
event that's going to affect the entire
course of the series it's probably gonna
be self-contained to each show so if
they deal with time travel they're
mostly just gonna deal with time travel
on the flash and if something happens on
arrow with like Rachel in the League of
Assassins they'll just deal with that on
arrow but next question Edward asks for
next week's bonus vid
yo can you talk about caitlin snow
killer frost I'd like to know what you
think they're going to do with that
character so you're asking like do I
think that they're gonna turn caitlin
snow into killer frost I'll just I'm
talking about it right now based on what
greg berlanti and the other producers
have said caitlin and cisco are just
going to remain caitlin and cisco for
the foreseeable future they feel they
work so well the way they are right now
just changing them in such a big way
like by giving them powers wouldn't make
the show better it would unnecessarily
complicate things next question Lord
Anubis asks so Harrison killed Barry's
mother or is there a third flash they
certainly want you to think that there
might be a third flash like unknown
blood sample how do you explain that
here's what we know right now an older
version of barry allen went back the
night his mother was murdered and fought
with a man in a yellow suit blood was
spilled but that blood belonged to Barry
Allen the producers have confirmed that
Eddie Thawne is connected to the
reverse-flash lineage in a really
meaningful way they have not said how
he's connected to it whether or not he
becomes a reverse flash or he has a
child who becomes the reverse-flash and
that child might turn out to be Harrison
wells when you start to think about it
that way it gets a little unnecessarily
complicated I don't think the show is
going to do that I think their
explanation is going to be fairly simple
he tested Harrison's blood sample and it
was not a match for either one of those
meaning that that man in yellow the man
in yellow that was fighting with the
future Barry Allen was not Harrison
wells that's just what the facts that we
have right now are telling us there
might be some timing why me explanation
it still could be Harrison wells but
what I'd like to see happen is is is
them reveal oh you know if it's not
Harrison wells then that means there's
another man in yellow it feels like a
very familiar tv-type twist where team
flash finds out Harrison wells is the
man in yellow they're like oh you're the
villain you're bad we hate you you tried
to kill my mother or you killed my
mother but then they start to connect
the dots and they say well we tested his
blood he was not that man in yellow that
means wait for it drumroll there's
another man in yellow who is he that's
why I think Eddie Thawne is going to end
up being that other man in yellow and
then the big WTF is going to be well
Eddie's my friend why would he go back
and kill my mother and then and then we
have to find out why that is there have
been some spoilery images of Barry and
iris
from the set from filming future
episodes that might end up explaining
why Eddie ends up hating Barry Allen but
there's no confirmation so I'm not going
to comment on those just remember the
facts that we have right now the night
Barry's mother was killed two blood
samples one of them was future Barry
Allen the other one they have no idea
unknown meaning it was not Harrison
wells because they tested his blood
sample thank you everyone for so many
questions though these are always a ton
of fun to do I cannot wait to find out
who the other man in yellow is or what
their explanation is for how Eddie
Thawne is connected to the reverse-flash
lineage because of all the DC stuff that
happened this week I wasn't able to make
the Marvel video that I wanted to make
so I'll try to get that out next week if
you guys have any special requests for
Marvel or DC videos be sure to leave
them in the comments remember new
episode of arrow but the flash is on
break till March seventeenth so I'm
going to do a bonus flash video Tuesday
night when I would normally be doing an
episode video be sure to subscribe to
get all that stuff it's gonna be a lot
of fun we'll see the atom soup for the
first time I'm really interested to see
what they're going to do with that
character the back half of the season
because if they're going to try and
develop a spin-off show they're going to
feature in quite a bit and we haven't
seen a whole lot of them so far well you
guys wait for all that stuff to drop you
can click here to watch my break down to
the Batman vs Superman teaser the
Aquaman teaser they posted and you can
click here to catch up on air on the
flash thank you so much for watching so
let's all high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you